hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome back to my safe loss blog
series so you've decided to use a Mac
there are plenty of different tools you
can use to build typical applications on
Mac but the one that I'm going to
recommend is Xcode Xcode is an idea
written by Apple it's not too bad it can
be slow on large projects for example we
use Xcode over at EA to build games for
iOS and I can tell you that some of the
compile times of upwards of 20 minutes
to games like Mesa speed no limits it's
also a nightmare to actually write code
because everything is lagging like crazy
when you've got a project that large
however so small projects like this and
to learn C++ I still think Xcode is
probably the best idea so let's go ahead
and install it okay so on your Mac we're
going to go to the App Store we're going
to type in Xcode and then we're going to
install it and of course this will take
some time depending on how fast your
internet is alright so once execute is
installed let's go ahead and open it
we'll accept all the terms and
conditions Xcode is going to go ahead
and install some components for us
okay so once that's done we're going to
create a new Xcode project for the
template we're just going to click on
mac OS and then choose command line tool
we'll give it a name so hello world in
this case and then under the language
we're going to select C++ you'll have to
put in some kind of organization
identifier like comm dot your company's
the suggested one so you can do
something like comm dot whatever domain
name you own it doesn't really matter
this is just supposed to be some kind of
unique identifier it doesn't really
matter what it is just put something in
there and hit next then you're going to
want to select a location for this I
like to store things inside my user
directory and then in a folder called
dev
so I'll make a folder called dev and
then just click create in there alright
so there we go
Xcode would like to access your contact
we don't really need that for this this
is basically what an Xcode project looks
like there's a few project settings that
you'll find inside the actual you click
on the actual name of the project you've
got all these build settings and build
phases for the most part we don't really
need to touch anything so you'll see
that we've all what we've already got a
main dot CPP file and we've already got
a bunch of code but I'm going to type it
out again just so that it matches the
other videos so basically we wanted to
include iostream into main st DC out
hello world and then we'll do our STD
cin get save that and then all you have
to do to actually build it is you can
hit product and then build now will
compile it for you there you go build
succeeded and then if you want to run it
you can just hit this play button that
will also build it as well you'll have
to enable developer mode if this is your
first time running Xcode and off we go
so the build succeeded and you should
see a console pop out in the bottom here
with your output what does he enter and
you can see the program terminates
successfully and that's it we're ready
to learn C++ on Mac alright you've got
Xcode up and running you're finally
ready to learn some C++ over the next
two videos we're going to start learning
how C++ actually works because that's
pretty much the key to writing it
properly until then make sure you follow
me on Twitter and Instagram and if you
really like this series you can support
it on patreon well I'll see you guys
next time good bye war